not really a religious woman but
sometimes there are those moments if
you're listening please I need you right
now hey what's going on everybody for
first we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Halsey she's at
YouTube record-breaking grammy-nominated
platinum selling singer-songwriter who
just released her third studio album
it's called a manic and it's available
now keep an eye out as well for the
manic world tour coming to a city near
you
Halsey welcome to the show thank you wow
that was quite the introduction
what's your headspace like going into
this um you know I've like no problem
while he on stage at Madison Square
Garden whatever I have to sing in front
of like 15 people I'm like sweating so
this is one of those occasions you know
my album just came out you think that
would be the priority on my mind and
instead I'm haven't been able to stop
thinking about this or a week
[Music]
all right so this first one is the
plastic yeah I started the handle here
okay eat looks close pre-standard mm-hmm
I know that you're extremely hands-on in
the studio and wrote or co-wrote every
song on manic and I also noticed from
the credit you have producer credits all
over the album as well beyond lyrics and
melody what are some of the elements of
sound engineering that take a song from
being like Oh a pretty good song to like
a huge stadium anthem well you know for
us it's a lot about like putting things
in the track that kind of help you
figure out what you're supposed to feel
where I'll find some sounds that I think
are kind of like indicative of the vibe
or the world and then we'll layer them
throughout the whole record where you'll
hear like a sound over the pad that
happens in track two and then it
reoccurs in track ten and you go oh I'm
gonna make the whole thing feel like a
journey so that's really cool what do
you mean when you say that you want a
song to sound drippy Oh drippy okay your
song is drippy it's like I don't know
sometimes it's like cascading since like
arpeggiating sounds or like xylophones
things that kind of like twinkle and
drop like sounds that sound really big
at the beginning and then fall kind of
into nothing it's just sound like rain
this should sound like River kind of
helps you get a perspective about how
the music should flow and then you also
include a voicemail from John Mayer ah
yeah and he seems to be from talking to
musicians over the years like pop
music's consigliere or something so
connected to artists and the mechanics
of making great pop music why did you
decide to include that you know I
actually kind of did it selfishly it was
for myself the the voice know happens
right before without me happens on the
record and John called me the week it
came out and was like this is gonna be
your biggest song it was like sure and
he was right it was number one I owed it
to him yeah I owed it to him to put that
on there I feel like we have this
conversation he and I a lot we're an
album is self-aware that it has a hit on
it it's kind of this weird thing because
I thought album is not supposed to know
it has a hit if you know what I mean the
call songs are supposed to be treated
equally and it's all created fairly so
the fact that after that track we
introduced without me with this little
voice note it gives it this like
I don't know gives album that's like
self-awareness it gives it a personality
kind of your fill dub much of a fighter
bigger I supposed to be you know
chomping I don't police that from over
here however whoever whatever you feel
good with mm-hmm
but I would say that that your your
textbook so far okay so your
collaboration with kpop supergroup BTS
it broke all sorts of Guinness World
Records including the most viewed
YouTube video in 24 hours
how do k-pop fans differ from say like
your own legion of supporters or Selena
Gomez fans or like the Barb's is there a
distinction they kind of move oh yeah as
a god I don't know how to put it like a
nation almost like they operate in
defense and support of BTS like they're
always putting together like charity
events and like donating in the name of
the band to perpetuate their good name
kind of but it's definitely intimidating
have you ever given any thought to where
these like super Finn armies like where
it all ends where it all leads to and I
never ever leave thread the needle on
this question so maybe I'll just talk
out these random half thoughts that I
have but you'll read stories about
they'll buy a billboard for the band or
whatever you read all these stories and
they almost operate like a record label
yeah you know and it's like all a circle
in itself so then I start to think well
what if this continues to evolve right
and then you can have an artist who
breaks on the internet and then can be
like self sustained by this fanbase yeah
like a crowdfunded artist exactly and
then at what point if they're like
working on your behalf like to what
point are you like beholden to them or
like wow you owe back yeah and then are
you allowed to decide to stop and
they're like no we put all this money
into you and this time yeah that's
definitely sometimes it can feel that
way anyway you know like when fans put
so much effort into like buying the meet
and greets and are like buying the
tickets or buying the merch it's
disingenuous that music is a business by
nature but it kind of makes it easier
because like
you can you can kind of be a brat to
like the corporation right I mean if the
corporation is your fans and like who
are you like who's the man you're
sticking it to yeah
[Music]
it's a Hawaiian no it's the feets from
Fiji what's the matter with me I mean
literally an idiot this think of pump
Polynesian REM nation character on the
front okay Giles okay I'm like
inspecting I'm really good so in a
Rolling Stone profile you made the bold
claim that you can cook a better spicy
rigatoni than expense-account hot spot
Carbone in New York City
I still love me some Carbone but I cook
a pretty good spicy rigatoni for the
people at home who want to channel chef
Halsey in the kitchen can you break my
step-by-step with the recipe let's go
okay well I kind of make it different
every time which is the nature of it
you're supposed to you don't I mean it's
kind of supposed to involve some batches
are better than others but it's
basically chili paste heavy cream a
little bit of vodka like actual vodka I
sometimes they use the cheapest one I
can find because it evaporates quicker
which is good yeah saute some onions on
the side get the onions super super
caramelized make your rigatoni sometimes
I like to use different shape pastas but
kind of making a sauce very very very
small chili paste then you mix that into
the cream add in some tomato paste kind
of create this like pink sauce I think
vodka sauce put all that stuff together
I always add a little bit of shredded
mozzarella cheese and stir it up because
it gives it that kind of like texture
when it pulls apart they don't do that
out Carbone um and then a little couple
of chili flakes on top put together salt
to perfection
good to go and one trick is to always
save like a half a cup or a cup of your
pasta water to add it back into the
sauce that's a little trick yeah
[Music]
Scotch bought it mustard
that is mustardy you're a remarkably
unsnap II
music obsessive you know yes you're not
above you know standing the boy bands
yeah I love Shawn Mendes yeah you know
what guess what yeah what I'm the way
here I ran into Shawn Mendes no way of
the hotel no way isn't he the sweetest
guy he is the sweetest kid it's the
Canadiens man they're all nice but I
don't know what they're doing over there
and then I told him I do free health
care I'm like we're on our way to go
interview Halsey for hot ones and then
we were like talking about John Mayer
because then they'd have such a close
relationship and then he's like cause on
the phone with John Mayer for like an
hour last night so John must have no
personal life it is all he's going
through his phone calling everybody
that's hilarious
what do you think is the single greatest
boyband song of all time
Oh what do you consider a boyband like
in my head the sort of like class like
that glasses boy they're the Backstreet
Boys the 98° the ridiculously underrated
Elvis I really showed your age with 98
degrees there um LFO remember LFO yeah I
mean that record is summer girl summer
girls is probably the girl on TV as my
is my I want to go officially on record
as saying that I like girls who wear
Abercrombie & Fitch but take them if I
had one wish is see ya
are you ready to go on here Halsey all
right
that is hot alright so at the fit spot
we always do this thing recurring
segments that we call explain that
Graham where we do a deep dive on our
guests Instagram pull out that need more
context is this Halloween or is this
just like a creative endeavor that's
what I look like all the time
no it's Halloween I went out I went out
with my boyfriend we just we just
started seeing each other and I met all
of his friends for the first time what
an impression yeah and he was a good
sport about he was like this is my
girlfriend like he was like super proud
but I was also like for god I looked
like that was like talking to people and
they were like hey yeah I was a good one
it's Halloween they got to get off your
back ah habanero that's where you're
getting me with all right I see you he's
getting real over there
all right we going let's go okay basil
basil it's like an evil herb garden with
my mouth it tastes kind of like a very
spicy um candle like potpourri we got to
put that testimonial right on the bottle
yeah that'll sell it for sure
halsy says this tastes like hippie
perfume so during last year's AMAs he
made headlines for a speech you made
while accepting an award you said I'm
thankful to the fans because they're the
people who really give a [ __ ] about
music what do you see is the disconnect
between music fans and then the
institutions and tastemakers that served
as the critical establishment in the
music industry hmm well it's hard you
know when I before I started making
music I was um a painter I was like a
fine art major so part of me that really
does care about critical acclaim and
there's an other part of me who's like
my entire brand has been like [ __ ]
critics like the whole time and I think
too now fans have a platform for it like
before somebody else owned the pipes
like there was the column or like here's
the music reviewer or whatever but I
love going on Rotten Tomatoes and then
you can see like what critics think of
it and then you can see what like the
people throatily and if I see a high
people number and a low critic number
maybe they'll want to see yeah hell yeah
I actually got nervous when MANET came
out because the reviews were so good I
was like everyone's gonna hate it
there's gonna be a yeah that's what this
means everyone's gonna hate it
someone gave me this really good piece
of advice once they were like if you're
on stage and you're singing and they're
singing louder than you are then it's a
[ __ ] hit and that's that's what
that's how I judge it now words to live
by
from Halsey are you ready to move on
okay
okay this is the flaky one gum popper
[ __ ] you go [ __ ] yourself I'm really
impressing myself right now
in the room not a dry eye in the house
oh yeah
as someone who's good at contextualizing
their life experiences in terms of
larger universal themes how have you
filed away that incident in which you
were accused of plagiarizing your own
poem cuz that's me it's like it's like
an absurdist parable for the digitally
oh my god so funny um I had a really
popular blog on tumblr back in the day
and one of the poems I put on it was you
were read you liked me because I was
blue you touched me and suddenly I was a
lilac sky and you decided purple it just
wasn't for you and is this like I was 18
and it was this it was this like little
poem about how you know you meet someone
and then they make you different and
then they decide they don't like the
person they made you and they're out and
you're like what you did this to me you
know I don't Lee if so couple years
later ended up in one of my songs colors
colors and people were like you stole
that from tumblr and I was like I stole
it from my tumblr but yeah it was good
it was humbling was a humbling
experience but now I don't post any of
my [ __ ] online until it's like locked
and loaded and like submitted to BMI or
Universal publishing or whatever because
I'm not trying to get called out you got
to lock it down
gotta lock it down I get a lot of [ __ ]
sometimes cuz my all my songs are
written by Ashley frangipani yes like
who's this Ashley yeah everyone's like
she's she's been she's the puppet master
behind Halsey yeah people are like who's
Ashley fringe Barney she's writing all
Hosie songs and like okay Nonnie all can
read
[Music]
here we go to Bob
I have a big [ __ ] bite oh yeah I good
I imagine this is what it would feel
like to drink acid I'm switching to the
milk
you owe me both whoa what in the world
coconut my first time yeah I've never
had coconut milk that is strange
okay so there's few things we love more
at hot ones than discussing the charms
of regional cuisine in New Jersey we've
talked about it with the Jonas Brothers
Joe Budden and now Halsey what Garden
State delicacy do you miss the most now
that you live here now Taylor ham Taylor
ham our bacon egg and cheese breakfast
sandwich whoa yeah
brah
I think I've burnt away whatever passage
was between my ears and my throat it's
just one open canal now I know
everybody's gravy trains come into us
coming to a halt okay probably the
funniest thing about New Jersey is the
way people save like Italian foods
like if something ends with a vowel you
take the vowel off so to say like moots
Adele look at out yeah
column odd
my ears are legging weird weird New
Jersey they have this guy to like I know
all about it
the local legends and like the haunt is
I'm about to become one have you ever
been to the Pine Barrens uh-huh
Jersey Devil that's where the Jersey
Devil lives I've in my mouth right now
it feels like have you ever been to the
gates of hell and Clifton did my eyes my
boss what was that place like I don't
remember I can't think of anything right
now
it was my god what oh where barony
houses are cool gates the hell is cool
Jenny jump is the coolest one what's the
story of this girl that was a chase to
the edge of a cliff when her parents
were abducted and about to be murdered
and they wanted her to save herself so
they said jump Jenny jump into the lake
underneath and supposedly she jumped and
died and her ghost haunts everyone and
there's another one I'm just talking no
home the profanity houses are pretty
crazy the inside of him is graffiti like
covered and curse words like floor to
ceiling inside the kitchen cabinets open
the cabinet inside the bathtub winter
says like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] blood that is some
weird things that happen and like a
super suburban state where there's not
much going on I guess I'm all of us are
bored because everyone we know live
somewhere cooler like Philly or New York
yeah all right are you ready to move on
how are you doing I was out quite late
last night rallied here we shot one of
these yesterday huh I'm hanging out let
me put chapstick on I'm sorry
don't solutions do not apologize
[Music]
why is there so much on it
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know what's happening to me
anymore so you seem to embrace on stage
mistakes like a wig flying off of your
head or forgetting the lyrics to a song
is there a story that stands out to you
now something that you can look back on
and laugh at um the first time I played
Madison Square Garden yeah I got on
stage at the biggest show of my life
let me sold the show out um like
downstage I'm like three songs in I
think I'm gonna faint I got incision I'm
like three songs in and I'm here for you
like where is before um catch me if I
fall
you're just qualified he's disqualified
this is my show now mm-hmm
okay so I'm on stage I make free songs
in and everything starts failing the
tracks the lights the visuals this whole
stage is completely black and I'm just
up there like
[Music]
I'm looking around the books going on
everyone's in my ears if we need two
minutes my two minutes no long two
minutes is on stage yeah I don't like
that I don't like when they push me out
they're like oh it's gonna be just a
minute just like just hold the crowd how
much what are you talking two minutes is
so long on stage when the show is also
supposed to be going perfect it's my
dream show you know what I mean
and I walked offstage and I was so
[ __ ] mad not how it happened because
what happened is somebody just tripped a
wire um for our playback laptop ran all
of our timecode and I love it now I made
it part of the show that during castle
the song where it happened cuz it's
superstitious first now I'll stop the
show stop the song in the middle of the
first chorus and I start the whole song
over and I tell them they have to go
even harder the second time so we've
kind of like embraced it but it was for
sure the scariest moment of my life
alright Halsey this half stab you know
he knew it was going on
[Applause]
you don't have to if you don't want to I
do have to I have I have a last tab
tattoo whoa
that's thing all right we're doing it
why can't I do this probably cuz I know
how many I don't have any strength in my
muscles cuz I'm using all of it to hold
myself up right right now okay I'm not
really a religious woman but sometimes
there are those moments if you're
listening please I need you right now
okay cool all right I can't I'm so
scared
I don't know you're you're doing great
well I might not I'm doing amazing okay
okay thank you
Dutchess hey you're too why am I scared
now I just did all of them hey I have to
I bite on this spot yeah it's kind of
the point on that boy okay okay ready
I'm ready okay
[Applause]
okay hmm here we are at the end of the
line you know we are so close to the
summit of spice Mountain yeah but one
thing that we have not talked about is
Halsey the gourmand here at first we
feast we have admired your food tweets
from afar so it is so great to now have
you in the seat so that we can bounce
some of our favorites from over the
years this is a new segment that we're
calling does Halsey still stand by these
food tweets first Trader Joe's is so
overwhelming there's so much going on in
like also what's even in that story they
sell food or only snacks this is like
everywhere I go I'm looking for the
produce and there's just only snacks
everywhere it's like what the [ __ ] I'm
the topic of snacks dry Oreos are so
weird to me need dunk äj-- yeah no can
you dry or do Oreo it's it's not
happening do you coconut milk the Oreos
yeah oh yeah also double-stuffed is the
standard I pretend that normal stuff
don't even exist not on the round I'm
not on the Ryder I could literally give
no [ __ ] about anything but chocolate
milk and grilled cheese in this life oh
you know what's so funny is I used to
stand by that and I found out I was
lactose intolerant which I think I might
have done to myself
I've drunk I dreamt I drink so much
chocolate milk for two years that
Nesquik gave me a lifetime supply they
shipped like cartons and cartons and
cartons of chocolate milk to Anthony's
house in the valley and we were living
together when I first started out and I
think I drank myself into lactose
intolerant so I'm not even kidding a
Spice Girls theme pizza place slice up
your life I'm a marketing genius and you
know what you have spiced up you're on
hot ones going down the gauntlet ten
vegan wings up ten vegan wings down how
is the hangover I'm dealing with a whole
new set of issues now so the hangover
completely cured and you're welcome
Halsey now there's nothing left to do
but meet you halfway and roll out the
red carpet this camera this camera this
camera lets people know what you have
going on in your life my album manic is
available now on all the
service providers is a bunch of really
cool videos on YouTube and I'm leaving
for the manic world tour this summer and
you better come see it thanks for having
me guys we made it I've been more
nervous for this than my album release
woah I'm not kidding I was like laying
awake in bed the other night my album
was out in Australia and I was laying
there staring at the ceiling literally
being like I'm gonna do this right I
come to be okay like like with this
panic in my chest I called my boyfriend
I was like have such bad anxiety he was
like about the album I was like know
about haha oh my god what is happening
to me hey what's going on hot ones fans
this is Sean Evans and I am so excited
to announce that after years of hard
work it is finally here
hot ones the game show on truTV two
teams compete for a shot at hot sauce
glory all the while eating some of the
spiciest chicken wings ever there is a
lot of sweating a considerable amount of
puking but then you also have cash
milkshakes
the pepper dome and the place is going
wild hot ones the game show you do not
want to miss it check your local
listings only on truTV
you
[Music]